he's Kevin Frazier from Entertainment
Tonight covering the Academy Awards
where are you right now Kevin I am
sitting on the Entertainment Tonight set
what time did you go to bed Dan actually
I was in bed by 11:30 12:00 o'clock I
called it her own I'm not messing around
anymore yeah you'd listen you're a
veteran you know you go out too late you
hurt yourself when you have to get up
early in the morning now to be back here
at 2:30 the party you wish you would
have gone to I'm Beyonce
who could you have gone to Beyonce party
Beyonce and jay-z held a dinner and then
a little dance party after that and they
uh that one was supposed to dance you
were supposed to come dance late into
the night we could have brought your
wife I mean could have been a fun night
right
yeah no no you know what it would have
been it would have been a 2:00 a.m.
nighttime be driving right to work at
the same clothes you know and that's
horrible
that's a bad it's bad when you we know
the Sun comes up and you still have on
the same clothes who won the night who
won the night last night um I thought
that women won the night but at the end
of the night I would say Tiffany Haddish
won the night and the reason I say that
is because if you went online folks like
Katy Perry
Tyra Banks everybody was going crazy
saying Tiffany Haddish should host the
Oscars next year and we're talking about
somebody who a year ago was making girls
trip was still relatively unknown and
now she was on the Oscars red carpet and
could be I could see them finding an
expanded role for her next year I'm
wondering about I didn't think there
were great movies this year I think the
last couple of years I don't know if
there's any of the movies where you go
we'll look in 15 or 20 years and say boy
I remember watching that movie but I did
want to add another category if I can to
the account okay but Dan of course you
can okay what if we did ensemble what if
what if you did it we're not big-time
actors not a big-time movie or scenes
like it's just it's an unbelievable
scene and and I was thinking about this
watching the movie diner whether at the
the diner and they just have the
dialogue there with these four actors
and it's so well done and I wondered
could you do that where you had best
ensemble Academy Award well so you're
saying ensemble or you're saying
ensemble for the koozie because they do
ensembles at the SAG Awards and part of
this when you say ensemble scene it
sounds like because you're hoping that
maybe one day Adam Sandler like movie
that'll work and you'll be in one of
those things no no this isn't about me
okay no no no double check but there
were there are scenes where you have
unbelievable dialogue and yeah yeah so
that I'm just throwing that out there is
something that it would be so tough it
will be so tough because then when you
start breaking it down at the scenes
almost every movie has at least one good
scene you know and so at least every
movie so it would be really tough you
know and then everybody would start you
know trying to game the system to get
hurt and the awards all we need is ten
good minutes
all we need is three good minutes
actually and we can you know we can win
an award so I don't know did you get a
chance to talk to Kobe I sure did and
you know what it's interesting Dan
because you know having covered sports
being there in the beginning for Kobe in
that when they won that first
championship in 2000 and watching him
and watching him with this girl he had
just meant that he was dating named
Vanessa and for it to come down full
circle and to talk to him on the red
carpet as he was getting ready to win an
Academy Award he said that this was way
more important than anything he ever won
as an athlete in the NBA because he grew
up expecting one day to get to those
height that was his goal he never had
the goal of winning an Oscar or being on
that red carpet so I thought it I
thought it was there I thought it was
interesting that this meant more in him
than any of his NBA trophies would you
rather have six NBA titles or five in an
Oscar I take five in an Oscar in a
heartbeat come on how about you yeah I
would too if you said I could have
Michael Jordan's six or I can have
Kobe's five and an Oscar
you take five and an Oscar and here's
the interesting thing you know because
there is a there's been a little
brouhaha and controversy about Kobe
winning this year with times up at me -
yeah when he walked on that carpet the
place erupted and the whole time
everyone was trying to stop him everyone
want to take a picture with him after he
won the award we're at the Governor's
Ball everybody that was a guy that
everybody wanted to walk up to and shake
it their hand Kobe was the first person
to go up there and get his Oscar and
great he won and he was like oh I'm
going up to get my Oscar and play and
I'm sure the Kobe sat at home he just
looked at that Oscar because you know
the intensity level that he brings to
life and he told me a great story that
his daughter if you remember at his
retirement ceremony he looked at his
daughter and he said you know you have
to enjoy the journey and with hard work
and intensity and focus one day you can
achieve great things and so his oldest
daughter when he won text him exactly
what he said to her at the retired
jersey retirement ceremony I was like
this so beautiful coach that's nice
I was also happy to see Jordan Peele win
Best Screenplay I'm always curious about
the timing we're talking to Kevin
Frazier from Entertainment Tonight I
thought get out came out too too early
if get out came out later sort of like
the shape of water or maybe I'm three
building around I I think it wins I I
thought it was that different you know I
thought it was great I see that is your
one great movie Dan and that's the book
I thought that get out was so refreshing
different so that's what made it so good
and that when when they released that
movie the expectation in the hope was
that it would make you know maybe forty
to sixty million dollars if it really
hit the jackpot but this was a little
film that was made you know they didn't
spend a bunch of money and so they were
hoping that hey hopefully we recoup the
money and make a few dollars and then it
moves on to your next picture and you
know they crossed well over 200 million
on their way to 300 million dollars now
and you look at it you could go anywhere
without seeing Daniel Clues face and
that getta that became the being the
emojis the PO
so you saw everywhere during the summer
and the other thing I love is that
Allison Janney told me that the way
she's treated when she goes to the
airport by black folks is unbelievable
now because everyone's afraid of she
walks in and the TSA will support her
because they have scored a lot of stars
I've searched yet they escort and she
still thinks she walked in she was going
to Atlanta and she was walking with the
TSA guy and all of a sudden she hears
over his radio all the other folks dog
you good I honor watch it'll be okay
it's just so entertaining because it was
something that she had never thought
about in her world but enough now you
know she's a black folks no Allison
Williams Thank You bud good to talk to
you again get some sleep and always
great to for you to join us
always a pleasure Dan and um you know
one day I'm telling you're gonna be
there at the Academy Awards brother one
day do you think when I die will I be up
there in memoriam no not at the Academy
Awards no I could tell you down now I've
you might break you might make the
sports Emmys oh yeah how about how about
the ESPYs I think you'll be in memoriam
at the ESPYs no doubt I I think that
they will go back and you know they'll
love you again and sing praises you know
how that is you know like they don't
love you until you're gone - I do they
really love yeah but Kevin let's say I
tack on five more movies and I'm up to
20 when I die
yeah no no way no I know I know you run
in these small circles but unless you
guys unless you guys have a breakout I
mean here's the thing you gotta talk to
Adam and he's got to give you a beefier
role and he's got to give you more
content you could feel some things man
maybe I need a new director and maybe
that's right listen I didn't say it you
said it who gets who can get me an award
give me a director that can can take
mine Kugler ryan coogler you call as you
get in the next Creed
the creeks to that they're making you
get in Crete to it you're like the
you're like the Howard Cosell they
attack this who you know needs to keep
going or something like that yeah you
know yeah but I don't want Michael B
Jordan coming after me he won't be
you'll be his compadre okay don't make
it soulful it'll be beautiful and then
you'll be at the Academy Awards next
year because everybody loves Kugler and
he I'm telling you this next Creed is
gonna be ridiculous I think unless
unless you will go to what Conda and
you're in the next black panther well
that's why he's going to say I think I
might want to shoot for a black panther
yeah I I can't see myself in black
panther but I appreciate that
hey thanks we appreciate a minute Jiki
and i'll see you soon
oh all righty thank you Kevin Frazier
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]